open the door
on the outside
[Music]
yup driver with your left hand
open the door on the outside
all the passengers keep your hands out
of the window so we can see your hands
now exit the vehicle while facing away
from me
driver no driver
face away exit the vehicle
keep your hands where i can see them
now walk back to the sound of my voice
keep walking
keep walking
stop
with your left hand grab the collar the
top collar your shirt
lift it up where i can see your
waistband lift it up
turn around in a circle
face away from me
alright keep walking
keep walking walk to your right nope
walk to your right
keep walking
you got it cory
listen to what he has to say
all right
passenger
open the vehicle
outside of the car
keep your hands up
face away from me
walk back to the sound of my voice
keep walking grab the collar of your
shirt stop
grab the collar your shirt i want to see
your waistband
all right turn around in a circle
all right
just stay where you are
put him in the car
all right
come back keep coming
keep coming
go to the right
you got him cory call him back
all right rear passenger
step out of the vehicle
keep your hands where i can see him
step out
face away
walk back to the sound of my voice lift
your collar your shirt stop stop lift
the collar of your shirt
yep lift the collar of your shirt
lift it all the way so i can see your
waistband
all right turn around
turn nope keep your shirt up
keep your shirt up face turn around
okay face away from me
all right you ready for another one cory
all right walk facing away from me walk
to your right no walk to your right
keep going keep going keep going all
right there's anybody else in the
vehicle you need to step out
real quick okay
23 copy
yeah they couldn't get it out
so where did this one was stolen
from patreon from the car yeah this
morning so that's going to be it
so they stole that have been
okay that's what i was wondering